[MUSIC PLAYING]
LORENA CROWLEY:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We host webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Lorena
Crowley, and I'm here
today to talk to you about
managing Chrome Browser
updates in your enterprise.
As enterprises look to
adopt Chrome Browser
or make it its primary
browser, the topic
of how to manage
updates comes up often.
In today's session, we'll talk
through some of your options
for managing updates
and give you some tips
so that you can best
deploy auto-updates
in your environment.
Before we get
started, let's talk
a little bit about
why the browser is
growing in importance.
You may have already
noticed some shifts
in your own enterprise
that impact the way
you think about the web browser.
Research shows
that users leverage
22 cloud and SAS-based
apps across three devices
to get their jobs done.
We did some recent
research with Forrester
that revealed the average
user spends about a third
of their day in the web browser.
And there's an even
more connected group
of users that spend
upwards of four hours a day
getting work done
in their browser.
We'll talk about that group
of users in a little bit.
And we know this trend
is likely on the rise.
81% of IT professionals
report that they'll
continue to view cloud and
SAS app adoption as a priority
when they explore the
adoption of new apps
in their environment.
I talked about this idea of a
more connected type of worker.
At Google Cloud, we call these
members of the workforce cloud
workers.
These cloud workers are highly
reliant on browser and web
applications to
get their jobs done
and also have a highly remote
and mobile working style.
One in four workers are
actually already considered
cloud workers.
And some of you might consider
yourself cloud workers.
Because of cloud-based app
adoption and the growth
of cloud workers, the
importance of the browser
has elevated across
the enterprises.
The browser is no
longer a passive tool
used to browse data.
It's now the crux of
where business users go
to access the critical
applications they
need to be productive.
I know when I go to
work in the morning,
the browser is the
first thing that I open.
And for people like
me, the browser
has actually become my desktop.
It's the place I go to get my
work done and to be productive.
Because people are
spending so much more
time in their browser, it's
more important than ever
before for IT to really have
a strategy around the benefits
of the modern browser.
When we talk to
our customers who
are adopting Chrome Browser
in their enterprise,
the benefits that they find
are really in three key areas.
Let's talk about management.
Chrome Browser makes it simple
for IT to manage through
their existing management tools.
For example, you can
manage hundreds of policies
through group policy.
We make these
templates available.
And I'll show you exactly where
you can find those later on.
For Mac users, we
offer documentation
on how you can manage
through PLISTs.
And we also offer the option of
managing your browser instances
right from the cloud in
the Google Admin console.
We'll be opening
up this capability
to IT admins that aren't
Google Admins today
in the coming months.
At that point, we'll have
a single destination for IT
to manage Chrome
Browser instances
across all of the different
platforms in their environment.
Security is also critical.
Chrome Browser is constantly
increasing built-in security
capabilities for its
broader user base.
And those benefits extend
to the enterprise as well.
For example, the Safe Browsing
service offered by Google
helps users be
prevented from visiting
infected or potentially
malicious websites.
And our Sandboxing and Site
Isolation capabilities ensures
that threats cannot spread
from within or between tabs,
making sure that these
threats cannot spread across
your network.
With IT's ability to enforce
and add additional policies
and controls, enterprises
find that they can get Chrome
to a secure state that means
even the most stringent
security requirements.
And of course, there's
your happy users.
Chrome Browser offers
a familiar experience
that your users love.
So they can pick up
right where they left off
and be productive across
all of the different devices
that they use in
their working day.
At the end of the
day, whether we're
talking about web browsers
or any technology decision,
we know that IT is
constantly balancing
two very important requirements,
security and the user
experience.
While IT teams and security
teams might see this lockdown
state as an ideal state
from a security perspective,
user experience simply
can't fall to the wayside.
And we know that IT folks agree.
In a recent Forrester survey,
73% of IT professionals
said that employee experience
is a top priority when
they make technology
decisions in their enterprise.
Chrome Browser really helps
IT teams strike this balance
between users and security.
And auto-updates
are no exception.
You're here today to learn more
about the Chrome Browser update
model.
And it's a great example
of how IT teams can promote
both the latest security
capabilities while offering
a great user experience.
Automatic updates are
standard for Chrome Browser.
And let's look at
exactly why that's
our primary recommendation
for enterprises.
Chrome's commitment
to delivering
continuous enhancements
provides a fast and easy way
to keep your
employees productive.
All of that is alongside timely
vulnerability mitigations
and new security capabilities.
So with auto-updates
running, your enterprises
get fast and instant access
to the latest browser
with the most advanced
protections available to them.
And with auto-updates, you
eliminate the need for IT
to handle manual
patching efforts,
freeing up IT's
time and resources.
And there's great
benefits for users, too.
For example, they can get
an optimized experience
on the modern web apps that
they use by using the latest
version of the browser.
And if all your
users are running
on the same version
of the browser,
it makes it easy for you to
handle any potential support
issues or challenges
that might arise.
And for the users, the updates
themselves are seamless.
It just takes a simple
refresh, and they're
guaranteed to be on the
latest version that's
available to them.
And for our customers who've
opted into Chrome enterprise
support, they get
24/7 access to Chrome
experts to help them with
their deployment and browser
installations.
And they'll have the
peace of mind knowing
that their users are
on the latest supported
version of the browser.
You might be wondering how
Chrome Browser's update
model compares to other
modern or legacy browsers.
Chrome sets the pace in browser
updates for the industry.
But we'll let the metrics
speak for themselves.
We always encourage fast
and frequent auto-updates
as best practice.
But we know some enterprises
have unique testing
or internal
requirements that might
make it challenging to stay
on automatic update models.
So we do have some
options available
for you to manage this process.
Let's take a look at
these more closely.
Even if your organization
has the desire
to benefit from
auto-updates, you
could have some
internal challenges
that make this difficult.
Some of those common things
include concerns around
application compatibility,
unique testing requirements,
change management processes
that you're required to follow,
internal security reviews,
and even regulatory
requirements.
If, for these reasons
or others, auto-updates
aren't exactly for
your organization,
you can turn off the
auto-update functionality.
We just want to make sure
that you're aware that it's
a bit of a trade-off.
You may not be running with
the latest security releases.
And when it comes to UI
changes or other enhancements,
your users may not be getting
the latest and greatest
experience that
we have to offer.
We'll also cover some options
you have for looking ahead
to the Beta channel,
because there
are some great ways that you can
take advantage of early access
to that Beta channel to get
ahead on some of the testing
or internal requirements
that might make auto-updates
a little bit more viable
for your organization.
Let's talk about the
Chrome release cycles
so you know exactly
what to expect.
The Chrome release cycle
runs roughly every six weeks,
moving from Beta into Stable in
time for the next Beta release.
The ideal time for
you to test your apps
is during those first two
weeks of a Beta release.
If you find any
issues with Chrome,
you should immediately
report them to Google
within this two-week window.
That will help us
ensure that we're
delivering a stable
version that's
going to be great for
you and your users.
And Chrome Browser has
multiple release channels.
You have access to
all of these, and you
can access them as early
as your organization wants.
By leveraging the various
release channels and testing,
you can be in an
auto-update world
while still having the
opportunity to adequately test
in your enterprise.
All of these channels,
ranging from Chrome Canary
across to Chrome Stable,
are available to you.
At a minimum, we recommend
that your organization
leverages the Beta version
for testing internally.
Each stable release marks
a major version release.
And each Chrome platform has a
different stable rollout plan.
It's important to
note that this can
vary based on circumstances.
But this is a good general
guide that can help you
with your planning.
Today we're mostly going
to focus on desktops.
The desktop consists of three
main platforms, Windows, Macs,
and Linux.
Linux is ramped up
100% immediately.
Mac and Windows,
on the other hand
follow a staged rollout plan,
starting at 5%, moving to 15%,
going up to 50%, and
then reaching 100%.
You may notice this
rollout process
within your organization if
you're using auto-updates.
This staging process allows
for any potential issues
to be detected early.
In a sense, we're
offering your organization
a built-in safeguard
for auto-updates.
We've talked about
testing quite a bit here.
But how should you go
about internal testing?
We have a few tips for you.
First off, you should be
leveraging release notes that
are available on the
Help Center to help
you understand what's new.
They're released within a few
weeks of the Beta release,
and they highlight
any new functionality
that could be of interest
to your enterprise.
In some cases, we'll even
highlight future changes,
coming and upcoming releases
so that you can plan ahead.
We also suggest that you
enable a group of users
within your organization
to become testers.
You might be surprised
at how some users are
interested in wanting to be
a part of these early testing
groups.
We also recommend that you
consider some automated testing
around features and applications
that are leveraging Chrome.
Overall, it's a good idea to
invest your internal testing
resources in Chrome as well.
We know a lot of
organizations have
dedicated teams that focus
on testing on premise apps.
The browser itself
sometimes gets forgotten.
And with each update,
Chrome Browser is changing.
So as your users rely
more on the browser,
it makes sense to have
some resources that
have ownership over the testing
of their apps on Chrome Browser
and the browser itself.
No matter what,
the best thing is
to find a process or cycle that
works for your organization.
You might find that
auto-updates are actually
easier for your team to
manage than you thought.
If we look at a great way
we see some organizations
segment their users and
maximize their use of updates,
it looks something like this.
There might be a small
group of select Beta users.
They're serving as an
internal source of QA,
really testing out the
browser latest release
on the applications and things
that they do on a daily basis.
Then the majority of your users
will be on the Stable version,
running auto-updates,
always making sure
that they're on the latest and
greatest version of Chrome.
Then you might have
a much smaller group
of exception users
that happen to be
pinned on a version of Chrome.
Again, we really encourage
this being the exception.
We'll talk a little
bit more about that
among all of your options.
Across the board, you
can approach updates
with Chrome in four
different ways.
If you haven't caught on
yet, our recommendation
is to keep auto-updates
on and enabled.
It's the default. And we
make additional policies
available to help you make
sure these updates actually
take place.
For example, you
can use a policy
that designates users to refresh
their browser within a given
time frame.
That makes sure they don't
miss any critical updates
because they haven't
refreshed or restarted
their browser in a while.
Another option you have is to
disable auto-updates, but issue
periodic updates on your own.
Most organizations handle this
through a third-party software
distribution tool,
using manual GPO
updates, or other processes.
You can also disable
updates entirely,
pinning your user to
a specific version.
As discussed before, this
is really only recommended
to be an exception.
And we want to make sure
that you're limiting this
so that folks are getting
the maximum security and user
experience benefits from Chrome.
In some cases, you might need
to take a mixed approach.
You might need to have some
of these pinned users based
on a very specific
business need,
whether it's an application
requirement or some sort
of security and
compliance reason,
while your broader
group can still
be benefiting from the use
of auto-updates or scheduled
updates.
We're going to quickly
show you how you can
get started managing updates.
I'm going to visit
chrome.com/enterprise,
which is the download page that
includes all of the downloads,
files, and templates and more
that you need to manage Chrome
Browser in your enterprise.
Let's focus on Windows.
You'll see that we
have enterprise bundles
and standalone MSI
files, which you
would need to retrieve if you
decide to disable auto-updates.
We make templates available
for Google updates.
This is for updates
across Google Services,
including Chrome.
On the next tab, you
can see documentation
that we make available for
managing those updates.
It will guide you through
the downloading process
and the process for installing
templates into the Windows
Policy Definitions folder.
On the next tab, you'll
see some GitHub files
that one of our Chrome
deployment specialists
has made available.
This script will kick off the
download of the GPO templates,
unzip, and install them into
the Windows Policy Definitions
folder.
This is an alternative to
the manual steps outlined
in the previous steps.
From here, you'll be able
to view policy options
around disabling
auto-updates, dive into Policy
Settings to set
auto-updates, manage timing
of your auto-updates, and
you can enforce policies
like the one that prompts
your users to restart
to trigger a browser update
Let's suppose you've
decided that you
want to use software
distribution
for your initial
deployment of Chrome.
This is a common scenario.
The steps would look a
little something like this.
You would go through an
initial discovery process
to understand what's
currently on your desktops.
Perhaps there are users
of versions of Chrome
that were
self-installed by users.
Once you've done this discovery,
you'll want to build out
your enterprise Chrome package
using the MSI that we saw when
we visited
chrome.com/enterprise.
The next thing you want to do is
identify a group of pilot users
to install this on.
Based on the feedback you
receive and any of the change
management or release
management processes
you need to go through, you
can move through that step.
Then you'll move on
to installing Chrome
into your production
environment.
Once you've done that rollout,
you can focus on updates
and really put yourself
in maintenance mode
around the browser.
As you can see, if you've
completed that cycle
and decided to leave
updates on, you'll
really only need to focus on
the feedback and the updates.
And you'll have the
assurance that, every six
weeks, your enterprise is
getting the latest and greatest
updates.
If you decide to
disable auto-updates,
though, you can plan to
issue periodic updates.
But you'll look at repeating
many of these same steps
again for each time you update.
As you can see, you can get
significant time savings
by staying on the
auto-update model.
Another topic that
comes up around updates
is around the ADM,
ADMX templates
that we make available.
With each release, new GPO
templates become available.
That's often because we're
introducing new policies
around management and control.
So if you see that there's
new policies that you
want to take advantage
of in a given release,
you'll need to visit that
same Chrome Enterprise site
and install these
files separately.
At the end of this
session, I'll provide you
a link to where you can see
an updated policy list, which
should serve as a
great guide for you
to review when you
want to determine
when you're ready to go and
install new template updates.
Another question we get is
around Legacy Browser Support.
Legacy Browser Support
is an extension
available to enterprises right
within the enterprise bundle.
It's a great tool that allows
you to predetermine which
set of legacy apps, legacy
URLS, will open dynamically
in the legacy browser--
for example, Internet Explorer.
Enterprises love
Legacy Browser Support
because it allows them to keep
their user's primary browsing
experience within Chrome
Browser, where they can benefit
from all the
security capabilities
and access their modern apps.
Then when a user goes
to use a legacy app,
they'll automatically
get redirected
into Internet Explorer.
And once they're ready to
browse or use a different app,
they'll be redirected
dynamically
right back into Chrome.
This is great for
these scenarios
where an enterprise
is living partway
between a modern and
a legacy app world.
This extension is
updated periodically.
But it's not included
in the auto-updates.
So you'll just want to
make sure that you're
planning on reviewing
those updates
and distributing
them accordingly
as it makes sense for
your organization.
Legacy Browser
Support is an example
of one popular extension.
And it's a Google extension.
But we know, in your
enterprise, you probably
have quite a few
third-party extensions
that your users love to use
in their environment to help
make them more productive.
Managing updates for
third-party extensions
comes up sometimes too.
Extension management is built
into the Chrome enterprise
bundle.
There's a variety of
different policies
that really lets you control
access to extensions.
You can even get very granular
around permission controls
that are allowed around
these extensions.
But when it comes to updating
them, you have a few choices.
The web store can
allow for auto-updates.
Or you can decide to pin
extensions in your environment.
Your organization
should really decide
what approach makes sense
around managing and updating
the extensions in
their environment.
We've covered a
lot of information.
But what can your
teams be doing today?
And what early next
steps can you take?
Well, for starters, it's
a great conversation
to have around what your
bandwidth and tolerance is
for new updates within
your organization.
There's really a
trade-off that happens.
Do you want the security
enhancements guaranteed
with the latest
version of the browser,
or would you rather control
timing of updates on your own?
Your team should spend
a little bit of time
getting familiar with
some of the release
cycles I mentioned today.
Really determine how you can
possibly maximize testing
within your organization
based on the different release
cycles.
You can also see if
there is an opportunity
to segment your users.
In a lot of
organizations, there's
a group of users that would
do great on auto-updates.
That way, if you're deciding
to manage or pin updates,
it's really for an
isolated group of users.
That will take the
burden off of your team
when it comes to managing
and securing the browser.
And of course,
you'll want to make
sure that you're reviewing
the enterprise release notes
that we make available
to you often and early.
It will give you
great visibility
into changes coming ahead
that your organization can
plan accordingly.
I've talked about a lot
of information today.
And I wanted to end our
session with some useful links
that you might find beneficial.
chrome.com/enterprise is
the page that we visited
in the demo, where you got
to see all of the resources
available to you
in a single place.
That page is updated
with every release
and includes access to
Dev and Beta versions.
We talked a little bit about
the Chrome Browser enterprise
support offering.
That's an optional
24/7 email and phone
access to Google Support.
That's something that you can
visit our website and contact
sales to learn more about.
We also have a team of
enterprise browser support
specialists that can help you
and answer any questions you
might have about Chrome Browser
adoption in your environment.
They can be reached at
this email alias here.
Additionally, as you look
at how new policies are
made available to you,
there's a complete policy list
that you can visit
visiting this URL here.
It'll give you good visibility
into the latest policies so you
can decide when it's the right
time for you to go and update
your policy templates from
chrome.com/enterprise.
You can also visit the
release notes at this URL.
You'll also have an
opportunity there
to sign up to receive updated
release notes automatically
via email.
And of course, the
Google Chrome Enterprise
Help Center, which is
a great resource where
you can get all of the best
documentation and information
that you need so that you can
best manage current browser
in your environment.
I hope you found
the session helpful.
Stay tuned for a live Q&A. We
will be back in less than a
minute to answer your questions.
Let's take a look at
some common questions
that we get around managing
Google Chrome updates.
One question we get is
whether release notes
cover all updates.
That's a good question.
What our enterprise release
notes really aim to do
is look at some of the
changes to Chrome Browser,
the policies, and
relevant extensions
that have the potential
to impact your enterprise.
We try and highlight and
focus on those major changes.
So while you won't get
an exhaustive list of all
the changes to Chrome Browser,
this is a great resource
and a great starting
point to help you
as you plan out your testing
and rollouts of new versions
of Chrome Browser.
Another question we got is
around the stage rollouts.
We've had some enterprises ask
if they can opt specific users
into getting immediate
rollouts instead of waiting
for that stage rollout.
Unfortunately, the stage
rollout works in a way
so that we're able to account
for any early potential issues
and challenges and address them.
So there's no way to designate
exactly who those users are.
However, if you do
have a group of users
that you would like
on the latest version,
they might make for a great
option as your Beta testing
group.
Another question that
sometimes comes up
is around our enterprise
support offering
and whether some Google
customers already
have access to Chrome enterprise
support for the browser.
The support offering
that I've talked about
is a standalone offering, and
it gives folks 24/7 access
to reach out to Chrome
Browser specialists
that can help answer questions
about their deployments.
If you do happen
to have G Suite,
you already have
access to this service.
But if you're just
using Chrome Browser
and don't have other contracts
with Google in place,
this is a great option for
how IT can work directly
with Google to make
sure Chrome Browser is
successful in their environment.
We also sometimes get questions
around managing updates
for Mac users.
You probably noticed that
most of today's session
really focused on
Windows environments,
because we know that it is
predominantly where most
of our enterprise users are.
However, we do make
documentation available
to help you configure
and manage policies,
including managing updates
for your Mac environments.
And we do this via a PLIST.
I encourage you to check
out the Help Center
for all of that information.
Stay tuned for the
next session, CE Chat,
How Cloud Composer Orchestrates
Containers and More.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]